well hi I mean it my my daughter goes to
school near here she's 14 she's a
teenager and she was so excited today
that school was cancelled because of the
rolling power outages now I grew up in
Minnesota and Michigan and other sundry
places in the Midwest first school was
readily canceled for ice storms and snow
except her so I said schools canceled
you want to come to Stanford with me to
this class gonna be talking to you and
she's like no don't want to skip school
and then go to class so I'm sorry that
she can't be here because I'm really
excited to talk to you about what I
learned you know if I go back to 1989
the fall I know if he were like 90
that's a long time ago 1989 in the fall
I was a freshman at the University of
Michigan in Ann Arbor we were not as
well dressed as you all seemed to be
because it was cold that time of year we
would be you know in in four layers of
clothing sometimes it could snow in
October a few of you are nodding might
have been to the Midwest before and we
didn't have classes on entrepreneurship
back then it wasn't really a thing I
mean you had classes on business he had
classes on calculus in psychology and
all the normal freshman weed out classes
that you took so I first just wanted to
recognize Stanford and and many of the
great universities that I've been
involved in for investing in this
concept that is entrepreneurship because
the world needs more entrepreneurs the
world needs more people who are willing
to look at a set of problems that maybe
are becoming more important than we
think they might be maybe have just not
been well solved in the past or that
maybe by solving we could change the
world together and so I'm thrilled to
see that this is a well attended popular
course as was advertised to me when I
was asked to be here so I appreciate you
all making the time I wanted to start
and just talk a little bit about how you
get from 1989 you know econ 101 in Ann
Arbor Michigan as a freshman to CEO of
public sass company in Silicon Valley be
cuz it's probably not as straightforward
as you think I mean when I finished high
school and got to college I thought well
I'll make sure I pick the right major
and I'll take all the right classes I'll
get the right grades then I'll get the
right first job and then I'll get the
right for second job then I will
obviously be a CEO one day like that's
how it will work
my journey or adventure as I like to
think of it couldn't have been further
from that so I am I'm sort of the
epitome of middle-class Midwestern
average I'm 5'4 that's the average
height of the North American woman I got
average grades I went to I took classes
in in the liberal science and arts sort
of part of Michigan which is pretty
average it's what you do if you don't
know what your major is gonna be I was a
reasonably good student but not great
has proven by my average grades and I
came from an average family which at the
time there were four kids in my family
that was pretty normal back then so
nothing exceptional at all about me and
when I think about how how someone like
me gets from there they're you know 1989
sitting in a room like this with by the
way no laptops no iPads number-two
pencils and notebooks to where I am
today
it starts with grit and so how many of
you read or at least looked at this book
by Angela Duckworth I sent ya well good
smartest people in the class this is a
great book I don't know Angela I'd like
to meet her someday
but what I love about this book is it's
a book about the science of perseverance
and if you want to be an entrepreneur if
you want to disrupt a category or
disrupt a company or business if you
want to create something that doesn't
exist in today's world or change
something that you don't think that
works about today's world then you
better be prepared to be tested over and
over again
and I don't mean hard freshmen we doubt
classes
I mean people testing your conviction
time and time again testing your vision
testing your philosophy testing your
approach your tactics the people you
choose the category you choose what you
choose and what I like about Angela's
book
is it's pretty straightforward
discussion on the difference between
being hard-working and being smart and
being resilient and when I think about
our employees at pedra Duty we have
about 700 employees when I think about
the employees that really stand out when
I think about the leaders that I know in
and Beyond Silicon Valley in tech and in
other categories or companies that I'm
affiliated with I'm on the board of
Estee Lauder for instance I think about
Fabrizio fretta or William Lauder like
what's different about them it's that no
matter how many times people told them
no people told them that was a terrible
idea people told them they were a
failure people told them they didn't do
well enough etc they bounced back bigger
better stronger
that's grit and they give you another
example people who are not pretty people
who are not resilient will have a bad
day any of you have a bad day today
yeah if it's okay like we all have bad
days they have a bad day and if you're
kind of a normal average person you'd
say a terrible day she's a really hope
tomorrow is a better day
please Lord give me a better day
tomorrow a greedy person will say dammit
I am gonna make tomorrow a better day I
resolve that tomorrow will be a better
day
gritty people own their own destiny
right they they they plan but if the
plan doesn't work out you recover you
learn you figure out what did what
didn't go well what what am I
responsible for that didn't go well
what do I need to do differently how am
I gonna execute a different plan
tomorrow right but you don't give up I
think that's a really important part of
it so I hope you'll find an opportunity
to read this book because there's just
there's a lot to like about it and it's
very instructive and I don't think that
you have to be born with grit I think
you can learn to be resilient I think
you can teach yourself to apply a growth
mindset how many of you know what a
growth mindset is okay see that's a big
Silicon Valley thing everybody knows
what growth mindset is I didn't I was
raised in
you know an environment where it was
more important to demonstrate that you
knew the answer or try and pretend you
knew the answer as opposed to ask the
questions and learn the different ways
you could answer a question and so when
I was younger as a leader I would often
fake it you've heard the term fake it
till you make it
probably faking it is you don't learn
anything right because everybody thinks
you know everything so now today like
I'm the dumbest person around the
boardroom so I often ask the most
questions right I try and ask the dumb
questions that I know people are afraid
to ask that's a growth mindset right it
also demonstrates to other people that
learning out loud is okay which i think
is super important so mooney when you
think about okay what does it take to
get from 1989 Ann Arbor to CEO of SAS
company let me tell you a little bit
about that journey so I wasn't really
sure what I wanted to do I kind of
thought I might follow in my father's
footsteps my dad was a hospital
administrator and so I kind of had this
plan I would go to school I'd do the
pre-med thing I'd get my MD then I would
get my MBA and then I would start
running hospitals I got through like the
first two science classes freshman year
and was like this medical thing doesn't
seem like it's gonna be a good idea for
the next eight years I don't think I'm
good at this I don't think I belong in
this community like I got to come up
with something different so I went back
to my counselor and said I got to find a
new major they're like well what do you
wanna do I'm like I don't know what
should I do
be like I don't know ya know you got to
figure that out well what do you like to
do so that was my kind of first lesson
in like this thing's this plan that I
had it's not gonna work we got to come
up with a new plan so that person help
me pick a few different classes and I
started to realize I really liked
psychology but I couldn't figure out how
I would turn psychology into a career
that was meaningful for me and I really
liked business I liked decon I liked the
this class called calculus for business
which was basically business associated
math it was awesome because everything
with story problems and I understand
story problems so it was a great
opportunity I realized like is there a
way I could put psychology and business
together so my undergraduate major ended
up being organizational psych and
business management turns out really
good areas to study if you're gonna boss
people around for your entire career
right so now like I've basically taken
this interest in you know that I that I
studied in school on how do groups work
what are the dynamics of a group how do
how you lead people to do things that
they otherwise might not do on their own
what is it that makes certain teams more
successful or less successful than
others that has actually become my job
my major actually sort of became my job
in a very roundabout way I still thought
I was gonna go into Healthcare
Administration after college and I
played golf at the University of
Michigan quite in an average way I was
not the best golfer I was an average
golfer in the golf team any any
student-athletes in here you got a
couple of the vak awesome one over there
so for those of you who haven't been a
student-athlete basically you're going
to undergraduate and doing a full-time
job at the same time right and you're
squeezing in practice training sports
etc what what playing golf and going to
school at the same time taught me how to
do was manage multiple priorities and
again I didn't know that I was getting
training for being a leader for being a
CEO at the same time when I got to my
senior year I sort of thought okay - so
I better apply to that master's in
health program or whatever that's gonna
get me into healthcare because otherwise
I don't know how I'm gonna get a job and
doing that and so I did that I did all
the right things I fill out the forms
you know did my interviews got an
opportunity to go into a masters of
public health and then a really wise
professor that I
grateful for to this day said to me are
you really sure like why do you want to
do that are you really sure you want to
do that I couldn't give him a concrete
answer it was like why is always what I
wanted to do well why you ever heard of
the five wise simon cynics the five wise
when someone like if you're trying to
figure out if you really understand
something about yourself or something
about somebody else asked them why five
times well why why do you want to go to
the health care
well because it's something I always
wanted to do well why'd you always want
to do it well because my dad did it and
I I appreciated what he did as a career
well why did you appreciate it well if
you get further and further and suddenly
I realized there was a lot of depth
sitting behind what I thought my life's
calling was so this wise professor said
look why don't you just interview with a
few companies that are coming to campus
and kind of get it's good practice
anyway get the hang of it and and see if
you know after you do that you still
want to go get your masters in health so
I was okay so I interviewed with Proctor
and Gamble they're my first on-campus
interview they were apparently very
picky I didn't even know I was invited
to interview with them because they
thought I had some kind of leadership
quality or something and in talking to
Proctor and Gamble I was entirely like
impressed and besotted by the people
that I met really bright super capable
high integrity very articulate knew
their business
super liked charming and engaging you
know that these are the kinds of people
I want to be around the same week I went
to orientation for this master's in
health program and met people who were
really quiet and really studious and
very not so engaging and kind of self
centric and I thought okay there's this
pot of people over here and there's this
pot of people over here I fit with this
pot so I decided that I would continue
the interview process with Proctor and
Gamble and accidentally landed myself a
job as a person in their leadership
rotation and I guess this was now 1993
it was quite possibly the best accident
in my life because Procter & Gamble it
is what I think of as a Leadership
Academy so back then you had companies
like General Electric IBM P&G who would
spend between two hundred fifty thousand
and five hundred thousand dollars a
person training you to be a manager
teaching you how to manage people how to
lead people different leadership models
to learn and try and practice and
demonstrate yourself and so that was you
know almost twenty years ago maybe
thirty years ago a long time ago and I
sit here today in my day job using
lessons that I learned at Procter &
Gamble in 1993 to 1998 right because
they took the time to educate me and the
reason I point that out is you may all
go off to start your own companies but
if you don't or if you have time to
intern between now and then you should
really think about working with a
company that will build and develop your
leadership skills that will teach you
what a good manager looks like that will
help you understand the fundamental
basics that you need in order to be a
great builder a great leader of people a
great manager and by the way there's a
difference between a leader and a
manager right because it's not easy it
doesn't come easy to everybody the
growth mindset will get you part of the
way but if you can get somebody who
knows how to formally instill
fundamental foundational skills in
whatever area you want to go into it
will give you a massive head start that
will stick with you your whole career
adventure
so a P&G I learned lots of things
because they have you work in sales they
have you work in marketing you work in
R&D and logistics and all kinds of
places I was you know 21 selling pampers
for a living I could barely even hold
the baby and they're like yeah you can
you work on the pampers brand I'm like I
don't know anything about diapers and it
seemed like a terrible idea at the time
but it's where I learned about brand
management it's where I learned what a
leadership brand looks like it's how I
understood the hierarchy of needs of a
consumer it's how I learned to deal
work in a very competitive environment
because Procter & Gamble and
kimberly-clark are like I don't know
like deadly enemies right I mean the
it's like the nemesis and the
arch-nemesis between the two of them and
when you're starting up a company here
when you're innovating you often are the
first person into a category and you
have no competition and if you're
successful you'll build a great category
that other people will follow you into
and that transition of being uncontested
to being contested can be a really hard
one if you've never built delivered
products in the market dealt with
customers in a highly competitive
environment so again like a really great
foundational education at P&G
you had the problem with P&G was it was
not a technology company the pace wasn't
fast enough for me I I learned about
myself in my second job that I really
loved a culture of innovation and a
culture of experimentation I'd rather
like have people not see the skid marks
when you go off the cliff so to speak
then do something incremental estaphan a
so I left P&G to work at my first
software company which was a company
based out of Dallas Texas called I -
technologies and I - was a supply chain
automation company it was doing what a
lot of companies do was taking an
archaic analog product process and
automating it so if you think about
supply chain like you've got a whole
bunch of different organizations that
have to work together to get from raw
materials to the sweatshirt that you're
wearing today right and in the old days
that would all happen inside one company
now it happens across big supplier and
customer networks within a business and
so a tie to one I learned how to work in
a in a very disruptive company in a
company that was changing the rules of
its category and we were basically
taking business from more traditional
manufacturing providers out there more
traditional manufacturer manufacturing
software companies and I learned how to
get over fear because when I - hired me
they they thought there
getting a marketing expert from Procter
and Gamble I was like 12 years old most
of the time I didn't know what I was
doing every day at work and I was the
most knowledgeable marketer in the place
and the next thing you know I'm running
marketing for a public company right
which is kind of like this holy
moment every morning you know they like
you literally it people probably all
heard of impostor syndrome like for me
it was worse than impostor syndrome like
I was like first of all these people
must be idiots that they don't know that
I don't know how to do this job and yet
so that in and of itself was a little
frightening and then at the same time
like and yet they're still trusting me
to bumble along and figure it out right
took me a little while to get over that
fear one of the ways I got over that
fear was to it was to take a less that I
learned from Procter and Gamble and
apply it there which was surround myself
with the best people I could find every
person I hired into that team was better
than me smarter than me more experienced
than me most of them are older than me I
think I remember looking around the
management table and every person in
that room was older than me and had been
at their particular job for far longer
than I ever had and I would just have to
wake up in the morning and give myself
the sort of courage and be perseverant
to continue to lead them even when they
push back so Jen you're asking me to do
this but it appears you know nothing
about this particular area dimension why
do you think I should do this why I'm
like by the way with adults in the
workplace because I said so doesn't work
well doesn't work well with a 14 year
old anymore either so I learned a real
lesson in leadership in that job because
I was constantly challenged by my team
constantly challenged but I succeeded
because of my team and so if you take
nothing away from you know that stint
it's the people who you surround
yourselves by are the key to your
success
right and the weakest link the lowest
common denominator will also define
where your ceiling is so to speak so I
think often people will there's an old
saying the the B team hires the C team
that's because if you're threatened or
worried that if you hire someone who's
as good or better than you they're gonna
hire somebody who's not as good as them
and they're gonna hire somebody who's
not as good as them and the next thing
you know you have a suboptimal team in a
big way if you have the courage to
surround yourself with people who are
better than you with people who are
smarter than you the chances are you're
gonna get better right it's it's mean
and I've seen this play out time and
time again over the last 30 years so
that was a huge lesson for me
I also learned there that that winning
isn't everything because there was a
period of time where we were winning but
in a way that felt out of control in a
way that felt potentially sometimes
lacking in integrity and the back then
you could you could announce us to offer
a product you could say we're building
this amazing whiz-bang widget thing and
put out a press release but it didn't
have to be delivered for days weeks
months and you would ship it on tapes
this is a long time ago you would ship
it on tapes the customer would install
the tapes and then they would determine
whether the product did what you
actually said it was going to do that's
not how SAS is now you know in software
as a service it's like uber you try the
app but either works or not you can tell
if it works or not you decide if you're
gonna use it again right but back then
there was a little more wiggle room and
I felt like we were often getting over
our skis that we would announce this big
great vision this is where the term
vaporware came from you ever heard of
vapor where came from this idea of
people painting a picture of what a
product could do but not being able to
truly deliver on or demonstrate that the
product actually did that and I wasn't
sure if we were starting to kind of come
up against that edge and so I decided I
needed to change and I had kind of
worked non-stop for I don't know a
decade at this point in time and decided
I needed to take a break and so I did
what everybody does I walked in quit
Lockton on a Monday quit my job packed
up my bags and went to Australia gotta
be out racing like everybody does
I had this little side story I I am a
little adventurous I like to try new
things I like extreme sports especially
those associated with water and frozen
water so I also really like skiing and
so I went to Australia because I asked a
few people like if you want to learn how
to sail if you want to learn how to race
where's the best place to do it where's
the fastest most efficient way to do it
because remember my first software job
was supply chain all about efficiency
all about how do I put something in the
front get more out the back do it in
less time at a lower cost so I'm like
I'm gonna do that with yacht racing
right so I the first thing I did was
find this happy crew of people with a
yacht and I delivered a 28 foot sailboat
from the top of the Australia all the
way down to Sydney over 32 days with
three dudes I'd never seen in my life
before it's a great way to log a lot of
nautical miles which you need to get
your certification as an officer or
skipper right so 28 days straight of
just sailing out in the wide ocean learn
it that's how I learned how to sail so
kind of threw myself into it three days
I'd never seen before but all smarter
than me more qualified than me more
experienced than me right and there I
just I learned the love of seeing the
land from the water their perspective
that you can get when you zoom out right
the the sailings it's really interesting
sport how any of you sail
I saw rower there we go that's what I
love about sailing is it's it's it's a
combination of engineering and physics
and teamwork and nature all at once
right and if you're on a great yacht
skippers on great yachts on performance
sailing yachts there's no yelling
everybody knows their role everybody
knows what to do no matter what happens
whatever unexpected thing happens and so
I'm in Australia and I'm yacht racing
and I'm doing all this stuff and after a
yacht race I get in an argument with
these guys from another boat we were
racing against over a ruling call and
that's how I met my husband
and my husband is Australian he's from
Darwin which is like the northernmost
part of Australia it's actually a
territory not a state he is truly a
frontiersman one of his claims to fame
is he will pick up a mud crab with his
bare hands mud crabs can clip your
fingers and hands off they're kind of
dangerous but so so he had I met he was
living in London I was living in
California the we trying to figure out
like how are we going to make this all
work together right and we ended up
commuting for about a year and a half we
could not agree where to live he want to
live in Europe I want to live in
California so we put three M&Ms in a cup
and let a stewardess choose and we moved
to Sydney I'm not lying this people is
how big decisions get made so I moved to
Sydney which again was a great career
decision because I learned to see the
world through an unamerican lens and by
that I think that when you were if you
grow up in the heartland you go to
school in an American University you're
trained by a stalwart American company
etc you see the world through one
perspective and it's nationalistic and
it's patriotic and that's great but
there's this whole huge world out there
so I ended up spending what I thought
was gonna be a three year trip to like
live in Sydney and do some fun job in
Sydney I ended up being marooned on the
island for 12 years is good Island if
you're gonna get marooned I highly
recommend that versus the one Tom Hanks
ended up on but I I would tell you that
in that 12 years I learned to see the
world through a different perspective
I learned to lead my teams from the
perspective of what does this mean for
our global customer base what does this
mean for the culture across our company
in different countries like if we do
this today what impact is it going to
have on the team in London or the team
in Ecuador or the team in New York or
the etc so lesson there is if any of you
have the opportunity to get
quote-unquote international experience
or what I like to think of as truly
global experience do it and do it early
because the
the boundaries in our world thanks to
technology are going away but the
cultures are still very different the
way a person makes a decision to invest
in you the way a person decides to by
the way a person chooses a partner etc
can vary wildly from one culture to the
next so get that experience and don't
kid yourself that the country that
you're from is the best because no
country is the best at everything no
culture is the best at everything and we
build great companies and great products
by bringing the best of lots of
different communities cultures
experiences together so that was a great
lesson for me in Australia I did several
jobs I you know I ended up working for a
private equity firm I started being a
board director there so I took my first
board seat in nineteen ml mm I guess
being on boards has been a part of my
career for a long time it's really
helped me as a leader to always have a
second perspective on how to think about
the strategy from a zoomed-out position
as opposed to the operations and the
tactics when you're in it it's made me a
better leader in my operating company
and being an operator I think has made
me a more productive board member when
I'm in a board room when you think about
who you're gonna bring into your
personal board of directors or your
board of directors if you're to start a
company make sure you look for someone
who's gritty who's failed publicly who's
had rough times because the people you
want on your personal board of directors
in your board room are people who know
what it's like to make a mistake and
will have empathy for you as an
entrepreneur when that happens and will
not panic when the hits the fan and
it will I promise you it will absolutely
so I think thinking about again who you
surround yourself with choose your
partner's wisely and if you want to
build resilience and perseverance
surround yourself with people who have
already demonstrated that they are
resilient and perseverance Zak Nelson
was the first independent director we
added to our board when we were getting
ready to go public
Zak as it was the
but one of the co-founders and CEOs of
the CEO of NetSuite which is one of the
one of the original cloud companies out
there he worked at Oracle for many years
he and Evan built NetSuite from nothing
through over the course of 18 years to a
public company and then it was acquired
by Oracle a few years ago Zack has seen
all every up and down that you can
imagine in business it makes him a
phenomenal board member because I can
come up with some disaster and he's seen
some flavor of it and he he stands back
with an even perspective and says ok
well have you thought about this he
doesn't go oh god that's awful what are
we gonna do he goes ok hmm so not a good
day and then we work through ok what are
we gonna do like what what do we do how
do we put the next how do we put one
foot in front of the other after this
disaster has happened so surround
yourself with people who have who have
overcome obstacles who have had to push
themselves through walls to get to an
outcome I left Australia in I guess it
was 2013 to come back to the US I had
been the CEO of a of a venture private
equity back software company that was
acquired by a large company in Europe
called ABB and I wanted to get back into
growth I ti2 was a growth company I
wanted to get back into building so I
came back here and I took a public
company private with a private equity
firm called Thoma Bravo and that enabled
me to learn a different asset class a
different investment style a different
way of thinking about how optimize how
to optimize a business so private equity
investors they sort of focus on
profitability and cash flow as outcomes
growth investors they're focused on
growth pretty straight forward venture
investors are looking for high growth
you run a company differently depending
on what you're optimizing for my private
equity investor in the case of TV they
were fantastic at driving rigor and
inspection in everything we did it was a
little bit like of like having a an
athletic trainer that you hate because
you go work out with them and they make
you throw up and they cause you to feel
a lot of pain etc
but then you come back onto the field
the next day after training with them
and your stret faster and you're
stronger and you're better so I learned
a lot of operational rigor and a lot
about discipline and cadence when I when
I work with Thoma Bravo that company was
acquired in 2015 and so in 2016 I spent
time talking to
I don't know 51 companies I'm probably
met with over a hundred and fifty
investors to find my next thing and that
was Pedro Duty and Pedro Duty has truly
been a labor of love
Pedro Duty was a hundred and seventy
people doing about 40 50 million in air
our annual recurring revenue when I
joined we're now public were you know
nearly 700 people and doing a lot more
more than a hundred million in revenue
we're you know we were the first
enterprise software company to go public
this year so we opened this IPO window
that you are seeing and continue to
perform I think very well for a company
of our size what I love about Pedro
dooty is Pedro Duty brings together my
experience from all of these different
adventures that have had over my career
so we build products for developers and
IT people and we offered them direct to
those people so you know we don't go to
we don't build a product that a CIO buys
and then distributes to everybody else
like they do with the ERP when a
developer an IT person needs our
software they go online and they try it
and they just start using it they can
swipe a credit card to buy it so it's
more like a consumer marketed product or
service it's more like a consumer app as
it grows through an organization because
what Pedro Duty does is help people
manage unplanned work it uses machine
signals it catch captures machine
signals from anything that software
enabled detects that there's an
unexpected challenge or opportunity
happening and routes an insight an
action to the right set of people the
right teams to work on that right away
so how many of you have been online
trying to buy something and you get the
spinner of death and can't complete your
transaction
I mean I have left abandoned shopping
carts all over the world there's a
wasteland of abandoned shopping carts
with my name in it because a consumer
will only give a brand one two three
seconds to get the experience right we
all have very short attention spans when
it doesn't work they leave and 90% of
them will not come back how many of you
go back and actually check out those
abandoned shopping carts nobody
so what paid really does this help close
the gap between that 1 2 3 seconds when
things aren't working very well to the 4
hours on average that it takes the
typical IT organization to identify and
fix an issue and that's important
because a typical retailer a minute of
disruption one minute cost them $200,000
and I don't mean the websites down I
mean it's just not working the way it's
supposed to it's just a little
disruption distraction etc so I've one
of the great milestones in my career has
been the process of taking Pedro duty
public we were not excited about that
because it's the be-all end-all we were
excited about it because we were able to
demonstrate that we could perform with
the best of the best in software as a
service and our financials and our
outcomes you know our benchmarked in the
top 5 to 10 percent of all SAS companies
on the planet and so we set a very high
standard and we wanted to demonstrate to
the market that we could deliver on that
standard but is also a big highlight for
me because we did it with one of the
most diverse inclusive teams in in the
tech industry so my leadership team is
gender-balanced over 60% of my team was
born outside the US the vet you know we
were balanced in terms of where
management roles go in the company and
it's very different than it was when I
arrived at pager duty my team used to
joke that when before I got a pager duty
the way you would describe the culture
was dudes from Waterloo because it was
largely males that had gone to school of
water you loot Waterloo university with
our founders and so to drive that kind
of change to build an inclusive culture
where people feel like they have an
equal opportunity to kill it
their career Pedro Duty is very much
about being intentional about setting
the tone from the top so again as an
entrepreneur you have an opportunity to
set the tone from the top and change the
way companies are built and run so like
just just delivering great performance
great financial performance or great
product is not enough it's how you do it
it's the values with which you
participate in a market
it's the values with which you treat
your people every day and culture is
defined by the lowest level of behavior
you accept not by the highest standard
you set so it means that you're gonna
have to be gritty and perseverant and
resilient when people say oh we've got
to hire this Rockstar person and we
don't need to see any other candidates
well wait a minute I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna approve a final hire unless you
can show me that the candidate the final
candidate slate was balanced and that
the interview panel that met these
people was balanced because if you have
a panel of four final candidates and one
is an underrepresented person they have
a 2% chance of getting that job if you
have a panel of four people and two of
them are underrepresented those
underrepresented candidates have a 51%
chance of getting the job providing the
interview panel is diverse so if you
have an underrepresented candidate but
everybody on the interview panels in the
majority they're very unlikely to get
that job so setting the tone from the
top living our values every day at work
being unapologetic and and outspoken in
the market about what we think is
important in terms of not just what you
do but how you do it is a big part of
who paid your duty is and a big part of
why I like being a CEO I want to sum
this up because I want to make sure we
have time for questions but so just
backing up a little bit there's a
there's a whole bunch of paradigms out
there that say in order for you to do
this you have to look like be like act
like come from this throw it out the
window it's garbage
every single one of you in here can do
anything that you want to do if you
surround yourself with the right people
if you get yourself the right training
if you are perseverant and when people
test your conviction and they test your
vision you keep bouncing back you keep
going back at them etc I mean people
test my conviction every day I set a
vision three years ago for the company I
still got people like we sure we still
want to do this real time work thing
this digital operations management think
we sure yes I'm sure
really yep still sure don't you think we
need something new nope don't need
anything new still the same one every
year I get up at our annual industry
conference and the first thing I do
before I write my keynote is look at
what did I say last year and what did I
say the year before and how do I make
sure we are consistent and we continue
to build on the vision we have cuz it's
a damn good vision no one's been able to
beat us at it yet
but you're gonna be tested and be ready
and accept it it's it's part of the gig
right and then the last thing I would
say is if you want to be a CEO if you
want to kind of run your own thing
remember that it's a lonely job
it is and again finding that personal
board of directors finding the people
that you feel like you can confide in
that you can share your worst fears with
that you can share your mistakes with
before you make them most of us know
when we're gonna make a mistake believe
or not you served a few you got this
kind of icky feeling in your stomach
about a decision that you're making
about something that you're doing you
just have this feeling that like oh it's
like an instinct number one listen to
that gut instinct it's probably right
believe in your gut but if you don't and
you go through with it like air it out
with somebody like here's what I'm
thinking about doing I just want to
check it with you like I have this funny
feeling that it's maybe not the right
thing to do maybe doing that before your
press go would be a good idea so I think
that's a snippet of 30 years right
but how you go from being kind of
average pretty down the middle of the
fairway
- pretty extraordinary set of
opportunities that didn't look anything
like the plan that I had for myself
in 1989 sitting in an auditorium like
this in Ann Arbor Michigan and I the
last thing I would say is when people
ask me what is it that's made you
successful like how did you get here I
would attribute it to two things being
super open-minded like there's a lot of
people tell you you should do this and
then do this and then do that after that
you know etc like being super
open-minded open to this sort of odd
sounding adventure or role that you know
maybe no one else has done before
etcetera but open to trying something
different open trying something new
right being willing to take risks
calculated risks I've taken a lot of
risks in my career and the vast majority
of them have paid off and again
surrounding yourself with the best kind
of people and never ever ever give up no
one wins by giving up ever so that grit
that resilience that perseverance keep
coming back if today is a bad day
resolve to make tomorrow a much better
one just a sec okay so open it that's it
thank you
so any questions first hand up in the
back on the far end I had a question
about you you were talking about how you
were hiring people that are more
experienced than you and older than you
how did you make decisions on how did
you challenge someone that's more
experienced than you and you're
disagreeing with the other way around
okay so I think the question is if
you've hired people who are more
experienced than you then how do you
challenge them and you know if they're
the expert I think what you're saying is
and you don't agree how do you challenge
them and how do you manage that conflict
so one of the other books I met I've
recommended for you is the five
dysfunctions of the team and one of the
dysfunctions is fear of conflict and I
think it's one of the other ones is a
lack of trust so I think any
relationship in a business starts with
trust like first of all if you've
convinced that person to join you in
your mission you've already created some
basis for a trusting relationship you
must be aligned in some way on the
vision but start with reinforcing that
alignment like hey so here's where we
said we want to go you agree yep I agree
absolutely now you you want to go this
way I want to go this way help me
understand why you want to go this way
so seek first to understand their
position because most people if they
have a strong point of view one of the
things they really want is to be heard
now explain why you have a different of
difference of opinion and spend time
working through that conflict don't
avoid the conflict like spend time
hashing it out go through the five whys
see if you can get to a middle ground if
you can't get to a middle ground which
by the way I like to get to a middle
ground I like my team to come to the
answer without me if they can but if
they can't then you decide you say look
I've heard everything you had to say
I think there's merit and some of the
things that you have to say but I feel
strongly we're going this way
we need to disagree and commit and like
after a certain point of time you got to
end the conversation and you got to go
and what you're really looking for at
the end of that conversation is that
commitment
other people who referred to it as agree
to disagree
i don'tlike agree to disagree because
there's no commitment in that there's
justice there's just a confirmation that
we don't agree think about how you get
to disagree and commit but I think if
you if you have if you if you listen and
you understand their point of view and
you can articulate why you feel strongly
about your point of view you can get
there okay so I think the question is
how do you assess grit in a new hire I'm
lucky for me I have this book here
chapter 4 how gritty are you okay and
there's actually a little
self-assessment in here that I really
like cuz a lot of people think they're
gritty
there are 10 questions that you answer
and I'm gonna read them to you really
quickly and the idea is you the way
you're supposed to answer this question
is to rate yourself one through five one
being very much like me five being not
at all like me and I'll just give you
example of a couple of them's new ideas
and projects sometimes distract me from
previous ones very much like me
not at all like me I am a hard worker
very much like me not at all like me I
finished whatever I begin hmm so talk to
people about completion my interest
changed from year to year so here's a
great sign of a lack of grit I get
resumes that come in all the time
senior candidates junior candidates
entry-level candidates and they will
maybe their average tenure at a job as
18 months won't even look at it
if you can't stick with something for
more than 2 to 3 years minimum I'm not
interested because what are the chances
you're gonna stick with me for more than
2 to 3 months minimum it takes you six
months to find a bathroom in your new
job
it takes you 12 months to start to
demonstrate you might probably add value
at 18 months you're probably adding
value if you've left the company after
18 months that means you were looking
for a job at 12 months I'm not
interested right so also look at
people's track record have they been
able to demonstrate that they have stuck
in something long enough and persevered
through obstacles in one of our
organizations we have a lot of ex
college athletes and what I like about
them is they've all been injured they've
all lost they've you know lost
championships at the last minute they've
been kicked out of teams you know etc
like they are gritty and resilient in
most cases and you can usually teach
them a lot of the skills that they need
but it's harder to teach that resilience
one more okay so I really appreciate
that you want gritty evil to fail like
let's say you have a job for 10 years
and you get fires and care in college as
a 30 year old freshman asking for a
friend
failure to show as opposed you say how
do you sell a failure when you're trying
to get a new job it's a great question I
do want to take one more question if I
can after this because I didn't get a
question from a woman and I need a
question from a woman how do you sell
that failure you start with what I
learned so what I look for in candidates
is show me what you learned in your last
job demonstrate your ability to learn
because if you're at a company that's
growing faster than 20 30 % that job is
changing every six months the company's
changing every quarter right so start
with you know I like start with one
taking responsibility here was the
opportunity I had in front of me here
are the things that worked against me
but here's what I did wrong like here's
what I screwed up and what I learned
from that is this and what I do now is
that right but I love people who own up
to their responsibility in their
failures who can describe what they
learn from their failures and can
demonstrate that they're like
learn again like that so in you know i
Adak i had a person come into a woman
that i interviewed and she's like yeah I
got fired I mean it was devastating and
I really should have been fired looking
back now I would have fired myself she
said to me and she said the thing is now
like there's nothing you can't give me
that I won't see through I was like when
can you start because as a CEO one of
the things that happens to you is people
like to delegate all the problems up and
I'm sure you've heard from previous
bosses or your parents like don't come
to me with a problem come to me with a
solution
strangely people still come to you with
mostly problems when you're the CEO and
it is so refreshing when you meet a
candidate that is very solution oriented
that's battle-tested right that is
unflappable that like knows how to do
their own laundry and that sounds
ridiculous but you'd be surprised at how
many millennial employees I have that
have never done their own laundry like
life skills matter people they really do
but I so I think it's just really
important to demonstrate that that you
took responsibility for that and you can
learn from it so one more question from
a female
[Music]
tell me about a decision that you made
that went horribly wrong and what did
you do about it I made a bad hire so you
come into a company there's a lot of my
company is backed by some very
well-known investors I felt a lot of
natural pressure to sort of get
everything right I'm also a little bit
of a recovering perfectionist and and I
hired someone who looked really great on
paper like head like fit to the fit to
the recruiting brief like nothing you've
ever seen before
charming effusive really likable in the
interview process within 90 days
I knew something was not right within
six months it was causing positive harm
within our team culture and our team
environment and I was miserable like it
was bringing out the worst in me that's
the just the the issues with this
particular person and I waited too long
to make the decision to move because I
one didn't want to have to go back and
recruit a new person for this job
- we felt like it was a really important
job and I didn't want to admit the
mistake that I had made and the best
thing I ever did was pick up the phone
one day and say like we I've got to move
this person out of the business and I
when I say I waited too long one of the
things that I did was I tried to fix it
I tried everything I mean I tried
everything short of bringing a therapist
in every day at work - like trying to
make people feel better and what it
really was was as soon as that person
was removed from the situation that
person was happier then the team was
happier and both people went their
separate ways performing more
effectively but I had no one up to it I
had to call my board and say I've made
the mistake it's not a good hire I'm
we're gonna have to do something
differently
I had to fill the role with an interim
person I mean I had to hustle to like
cover for it it could have been a
disaster they suppose the piece of
good news coming out it is I got far
enough ahead of it that it didn't become
a disaster right and I think sometimes
our fear of failure will stop us from
taking the action that we need to take
to get the company to the right place
but the firt one of the first things i
did was call a couple of my board
members and say this is a problem this
is what i think i'm gonna do what do you
think and lucky for me I've got gritty
perseverant resilient board members
you've been through this before and
they're like yeah one of them said to me
you know what Jen like like if you can
get 60% of your hires right that's
pretty good I think that was John
Chambers average like that was okay I
was like really only 60 okay I'm not
doing so bad I'm at like 80 so that's it
that's an example so look I thank you
thank you
[Applause]